>> Tucker: IN SECURITY FOOTAGE
OBTAINED BY FOX NEWS, TIME
STAMPED MONDAY, 3:08  P.M.
PACIFIC TIME, AN 80-YEAR-OLD
PART-TIME NAP A RESIDENT CAN BE
SEEN IN A SAN FRANCISCO HAIR
SALON, WET HAIR, NOT WEARING A
MASK, BUT SHE WAS ALMOST
ALONE, DUE TO CORONAVIRUS
REGULATIONS, SALONS IN
SAN FRANCISCO ARE CLOSED TO
SERVICES.
NANCY PELOSI WENT INSIDE, AND
SHE CAN DO THAT BECAUSE SHE IS
THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE, THIRD
IN LINE TO THE PRESIDENCY.
YOU CANNOT BECAUSE YOU DON’T
HAVE AS MUCH POWER AS
NANCY PELOSI.
THE OWNER OF THE SALON WAS
FURIOUS ABOUT THIS, AND SHE TOLD
FOX NEWS THAT PELOSI’S TRIP WAS
DISTURBING AND A SLAP IN THE
FACE TO PEOPLE NOT ALLOWED TO
WORK BECAUSE OF NANCY PELOSI.
MEANWHILE, OUR MEDIA WAS ANGRY,
TOO, NOT A NANCY PELOSI, BUT AT
YOU FOR FINDING OUT IT HAPPENED.
OVER AT "POLITICO"," ONE PERSON
WAS INCENSED BY THIS, AND SHE
TWEETED, AND WE ARE QUOTING,
"HAVE TO ASK, UPON SEEING THIS,
IS IT LEGAL IN CALIFORNIA, A
TWO-PARTY SYSTEM CONSENT STATE,
VIDEOTAPE SOMEONE IN A PRIVATE
HOME OR BUSINESS WITHOUT THEIR
CONSENT?"
IT WAS THE OWNER’S FAULT, THE
SECURITY CAMERA’S FAULT
DEFINITELY NOT NANCY PELOSI’S
SET FAULT.
IFIF YOU FOLLOW NANCY PELOSI
CAREFULLY, YOU ARE NOT SURPRISED
BY THAT BECAUSE NOTHING MATTERS
MORE TO NANCY PELOSI THAN COLD
HARD SCIENCE, SHE HADN’T BEEN
BORN INTO A POWERFUL POLITICAL
FAMILY, SHE MIGHT HAVE BEEN
ISAAC NEWTON, THAT’S WHAT YOU
CAN TRUST HER WHEN SHE SAYS THE
PRESIDENT IS STEALING OUR
MAILBOXES AND IT IS NOT SAFE TO
VOTE IN PERSON.
NANCY PELOSI KNOWS WHAT SHE IS
TALKING ABOUT, THAT HAS GUIDED
HER CAREER FOR DECADES NOW, IF
YOU WATCH MSNBC LAST NIGHT, YOU
WATCH HER POINT OUT -- THIS IS
TRUE -- THAT ONLY BAD PEOPLE
DON’T WEAR MASKS OR STAY
SOCIALLY DISTANT.
>> WHAT FURTHER EVIDENCE DOES
ANYONE NEED THAT THIS PRESIDENT
DOESN’T CARE LESS ABOUT THE
SPREAD OF THIS VIRUS THEN TO SEE
WHAT HE DID, VANDALIZING, BY THE
WAY, THE WHITE HOUSE BY BRINGING
ALL THOSE PEOPLE THERE, NO
MASKS, NO DISTANCING, AND THE
REST?
HE SLAPPED SCIENCE RIGHT IN THE
FACE, AND WHAT A BAD EXAMPLE
THAT WAS.
>> Tucker: DONALD TRUMP
SLAPPED SCIENCE RIGHT IN THE
FACE, AND THAT IS NOT EASY, BY
THE WAY, BECAUSE SCIENCE IS A
WORTHY OPPONENT.
STINGS LIKE A B.
BUT BY THAT STANDARD -- AND THAT
IS THE STANDARD NOW --
NANCY PELOSI DIDN’T SIMPLY
SLAPPED SCIENCE IN THE FACE
YESTERDAY.
KNOW, BY NOT WEARING A MASK AND
SNEAKING INTO A HAIR SALON
OTHERS ARE BANNED FROM ENTERING,
NANCY PELOSI DID SOMETHING
WORSE, NANCY PELOSI DROWNED
SCIENCE AND A 12-POUND DESIGNER
ICE CREAM HELP, SHE --